and let's be honest about this Ukraine
posed no threat to Russia and NATO is a
defensive organization that also poses
no threat to Russia and just my point at
the beginning was that you have
retreated the reason I said it's not
going to plan is you've retreated from
the capital president zielinski is still
in power you've lost thousands of troops
you've lost six generals hundreds of
tanks and other equipment it's it's a
humiliation really isn't it
no no it's a wrong understanding of what
is going on but what is wrong about what
I've just said
well nearly everything nearly everything
well you've lost thousands of troops
yeah let's go through it you've lost
thousands of troops how many troops have
you lost we have we have we have
significant losses of troops and uh it's
it's it's a huge tragedy for us
uh now about two regions Kiev and the
chernigov regions
uh so actually the troops were really
withdrawn from that region as an act of
a good will
during the negotiations between two
delegations Russian and Ukrainian
delegation and it went it was an act of
a Goodwill just to
um
to
uh well to to to lift tension from those
regions and in order to show that Russia
is really ready to create comfortable
conditions for continuation of
negotiation but it's just not true is it
because you continued if it was if it
was a a measure of Good Will why then
did you continue to bombard
Marry You Paul in the way that you have
to devastate that City if you really
wanted to facilitate peace talks you
would have had a ceasefire but you
carried on bombarding Mario poll and
shelling kharkiv and other places so
it's it's not really true is it
if you let me I'll try to explain
well first of all mariopal is a part of
lugan's People's Republic you know we
recognize them as an independent state
and actually the premier goal of the
operation was to uh was to to to to to
to assist those people of two people's
republics that were suffering for eight
years from heavy shelling from Ukrainian
military people and by the way during
those eight years no one would would
mention that would mention those
atrocities
that doesn't justify a full-scale
evasion Invasion does it I mean let's
keep this in proportion